enrollment is slightly up at CCSD but
follows years of losses and that impacts
funding of course as parents choose
other modes of learning for their kids
Ryan Matthey looked into this breaks
down why the change and what the school
district is and is not saying on this
matter
the Clark County School District may be
one of the country's largest but parents
say that comes with its own share of
concerns and as more students leave the
school district they're taking funding
with it I've noticed academically he's
doing so much better Ava musicon pulled
her then eight-year-old out of CCSD with
the pandemic forced classes to go online
she wanted him back in person ASAP so
when homeschooling failed private
schooling succeeded they do small group
classes there's only up to I think 10
per class and there's a good mix of
older younger kids it goes until eighth
grade we feel like we have the best of
both worlds
Odyssey Charter School does a hybrid of
in-person and online going on two
decades now a learning model
superintendent Timothy Lorenz says grew
the student body when most schools were
empty we're a smaller learning community
and we're also a blended learning models
we got everything done smaller classes
and more attention perks that seemingly
are pulling kids outside the district a
report from Tuesday night's school board
meeting shows a revised enrollment
number of just over 300 000
district-wide nearly 25 000 less than
its peak in 2018 and 19. what's that
mean for funding well nearly seventy
four thousand dollars in state funding
less per student with revised numbers
for this school year it's a total loss
of 32.6 million in the district's budget
in a statement a CCSD representative
contributed this decrease to a drop in
the birth rate since 2008 families
moving out of Clark County during the
pandemic and recent State legislation
that changed age eligibility for
kindergarten students that began this
school year
so let's put this into perspective with
some numbers CCSD may have almost 380
schools that's throughout the county
that counts for about 300 000 students
roughly but keep this in mind according
to public schoolreview.com about 103
private schools here served nearly 23
000 students and 70 Charter Schools
serve an estimated 54 000 students Brian